hi I'm Patti Kim from home theaters to
plush sofas hands down the family room
is the coolest place to relax but what
makes this area is such an amazing
retreat for entertainment could also be
adding dollars to your power bill and be
affecting your health we hear some easy
ways to trim energy and take out toxins
more and more flat-screen tvs digital
video recorders of theater sound systems
are becoming essential home fixtures the
nest of plugs and wires behind the
console is testament to how these
gadgets are the fastest growing source
of electricity use in the home strangely
enough a good 10% or more of your power
bill is actually spend on not using them
what do I mean well if you've got a lot
of those electronic devices at home
watch out because they're they're kind
of like vampires they're sucking power
even when they're turned off televisions
computers set-top boxes and other
digital devices all sip electricity to
power clocks easy on features and little
glowing lights you can slay your
vampires by unplugging devices when not
in use or use power strips to switch off
multiple devices when outlets are in
hard-to-reach areas if you're expanding
the home entertainment system consider
how much electricity you'll be consuming
the biggest power guzzler is the
television LCD TVs generally consumed
less energy than CRTs while plasmas can
use as much power as your fridge and
when you add on all the peripherals of
DVD players and game consoles you may be
increasing your electricity bill by an
extra 10 percent having a happy living
space is also about having a healthy one
traditionally making family rooms
comfortable as included wall-to-wall
carpet makes a room feel so much cozier
doesn't it no wonder people love carpet
but the one thing you might not realize
about carpet is that it's actually been
identified as a potential health hazard
you see all the tiny fibers of a carpet
can trap things like mold dust pesticide
and you're gonna love this
droppings of dust mites yep I'm totally
serious and all of that can trigger
allergies which is a lot of fun fibres
backings and glue made from synthetic
petroleum products are known to give off
volatile
chemicals and can cause irritation
the key to having a carpet is actually
cleaning it and cleaning it thoroughly
and often using a vacuum cleaner like
this one with a true HEPA filter is a
powerful way to remove those dust
particles and clean the air too
these filters are able to remove 99% of
allergen particles a nice alternative to
carpet is hardwood wood floors made from
renewable sources like Forest
Stewardship Council certified hardwood
bamboo or cork tiles are all good
choices following these easy little tips
will help you and your family breathe
easier and help create a safer and
healthier environment and while you do
that I'm gonna watch the rest of this
movie